il s'agit en fait d'un stage de
citoyenneté
particulier qui est destiné à un public
concerné par des infractions en lien
avec le racisme et l'antisémitisme et
les stages de citoyenneté qui est une
procédure qui est prévue depuis très
très longtemps puisque ça existe depuis
2003 ne cesse en fait de se développer
en le stage est prévu sur deux jours
il est gratuit il se déroule au mémorial
de la shoah dans le marais à paris qui
est donc d'abord un musée mais ils vont
également rencontrer des rescapés du
génocide par exemple du génocide des
tutsi donc ils vont être directement
confrontés à des paroles de personnes
qui ont été concernés par le racisme
notamment où l'antisémitisme
l'intérêt de ce stage c'est que
effectivement maintenant on peut le
prononcé à tous les stades justement de
la procédure soit ce qu'on appelle en
pré sentenciel donc en alternative aux
poursuites soient en poste sentenciel
c'est à dire lorsque le tribunal a
considéré que c'était une des modalités
d'application de la peine
par la voix de la pédagogie en réalité à
sensibiliser expliquer faire comprendre
c'est de prendre conscience de ce que
leur expression qui peut être écrite qui
peut utiliser les réseaux sociaux peu
importe le support a donc d' illégale et
qu'elle ne peut pas perdurer pour que
les citoyens et la possibilité de vivre
les uns avec les autres
c'est apprendre la tolérance à prendre
l'interdît ou réapprendre l'interdît